All families,
all families have conflict,
successful families actually illimited
and move on to actually building
positive memories,
so how do you do that?
I took a three day course from the folks
at the Harvard negotiation project
thinking they work with Israelis and
Palestinians and general strikes in
emerging markets.
Let's find out what they know to bring
peace and this changed a lot about how
my wife and I,
we used to have what I call it,
7:40 to fight every night the kids would
be down and we would talk about who's
picking up the milk,
who's buying the tickets for vacation,
and it would always just ended a model
with my wife storming out of the room
and what I learned was a number of
things.
First of all,
I changed when we have these
conversations.
Highest stress time and families is
between six and eight at night,
so 7:42 PM.
The worst time you can have one of these
fights,
so we no longer have difficult
conversations during this period.
Second,
I changed where we fight.
I would be at my desk surrounded by my
computer equipment,
a pie.
My wife would be lower,
she'd be her arms crossed,
resentful.
Turns out I was in the power position,
so now when we have difficult
conversations,
we sit at the same level.
We actually,
if we're having a really difficult
conversation,
have moved to our bedroom,
to a bench that we have this cushion
because research shows if you're sitting
on a cushion bench will be more open
alongside each other.
You'll be collaborative across from each
other,
more confrontational.
The point is there's all these new ideas
out there about reducing conflict,
so let's bring them into families.
Some may be right for your family,
some may not,
but I'd be surprised if you couldn't
fight smarter after reading some of
these tips.
For example,
one thing,
worst thing you can say on a fight,
is it I is that we?
Is it you or is it your mother?
Your mother and I may not be great,
but you turned out to be the worst thing
you can say in a fight.
You always do this.
You'd never do that.
Speak about yourself.
Speak about us as a couple,
but if you want to stop fighting,
stop saying you.
So let's talk about things that can go
wrong in families.
Even if the adults are fighting smarter.
The kids are probably getting into a lot
of disputes and they seem incredibly
petty to parents,
but the truth is even those petty
discussions and in my house,
it can be socks in your house.
It might be who's staying up later.
It might be who's getting to sit in what
chair?
So here's what I've learned is simple
three step process that can reduce
sibling fighting.
Number one,
separate them,
they're in the middle of the conflict.
Separate them.
Give everyone a chance to calm down and
reflect a little,
not only on what the other person did,
but on what they.
Step two,
and this is the most important,
have kids come up with two or three
alternatives.
Usually the first one is going to be the
one that they've come up with and they
may stick to that for a few minutes,
but after awhile they'll come up with
two or three alternatives.
Then you bring the siblings back
together.
At that point,
there's four or five alternatives on the
table and nine times out of 10,
one of those alternatives overlaps with
another and the kids are beginning to
solve the problem.
Again,
the key here is to give your kids the
tools that they need to solve the
problems themselves.
I used to think,
oh,
don't be referee.
Let the kids solve the problems,
but the truth is you need to teach them
the skills.
You can't just expect them to learn it.
Teach them the skills so they can solve
the problems.
When you're not.